Speaker 1: We have a bizarre video.
This is actually I have to tell you,
I love this video. This really gives me pleasure.
Roger Stone, former Trump confidante who was
convicted and then pardoned. He has a new TV show
on Lindell TV. Lynn Lindell TV is this streaming
channel from Mypillow CEO Mike
Lindell, known colloquially as Pillow.
And during what I think is one of the debut
episodes, maybe the debut episode. Roger Stone
has complete and total technical issues where
the audio is completely unsent from the video
he is offering. He's offering dog pillows
with a coupon code my pillow dog pillows.
And then in the midst of the technical aspects
going wrong, Matt, the engineer tries to interrupt
to get him to fix it and. Somehow Stone appears
unable or unwilling to listen to the engineer,
but the audience hears the engineer. I mean,
you you can't write something funnier than
this. Check this out. And I know that
if you're if you're only listening,
you won't see the visual aspect of the audio
and video being totally unsent. So just imagine
that as an additional comedic element here.
Speaker 3: You're an animal lover and you want to
do something great for your pets. Go to my pillow
right now and use the promo code stone. Later in
the hour, we're going to be taking your phone
calls in the segment we call Ask Roger. Right.
And that number for those you want to plan ahead
is 9013168404. Once again, later on, ask Roger
any topic, political, social style.
Speaker 1: So by multiple seconds,
the audio and the video are
disconnected. And now the producer
is going to jump in. This is beyond parody.
Speaker 3: For you want to talk about at
9013168404. Today is an extraordinarily momentous
day for those who believe in free speech. That's
because, hey, this is Matt here, the engineer.
Speaker 2: Is there any way you can send a live
feed back to us rather than a delayed feed?
Speaker 3: Twitter. Now,
this is more than just your random bill.
Speaker 1: Oh, this is just the best. So
going out on a lighter note today,
folks. A lot of serious news today,
but a little bit of a palate cleanser there.
Everything going wrong on Roger Stone's new show